I love stories about people getting
started and how it's not easy and you
were a door-to-door salesman at one
point probably not that long ago oh god
yeah it's I still have nightmares about
it so it couldn't have been that long
ago well well what kind of door-to-door
salesmen were you I was I sold coupons
it was one of these kind of multi-level
marketing schemes where if you work
really hard to make your boss a lot of
money one day you could have your own
office and I did it for two years I was
from the time I was 18 to 20 and I ended
up opening my own office and you were
good I was good I was a good salesman I
was good I think in fact I think there
are major lessons to be learned and door
to door sales that you use as an actor
you know in terms of just dealing with
rejection and walking into a room full
of strangers and being on and being
enthusiastic and stuff and yeah I was a
guy was I was good at was good at it and
you got to be in charge of other people
at one point oh yeah other idiots I was
I opened an office in Colorado and and
put an ad in the paper that said do you
like rock and roll music do you want to
make money call me so wait these people
show up yeah and then you tell them they
probably think I'm gonna be in a rock
band or something
well yeah or we're gonna rock love you
you read out the intelligent people they
just don't call ya and then you know you
here's my resume
in fact love rock and roll yeah and you
know you you take them out on a day
bobster did what's called a day of Oh a
day of observation and they'd walk with
you all day and watch you just get the
crap kicked out of you by all these
people and at the end of the day you'd
sit them down and say listen charlie I
hate to tell you this but you got the
job and then most of the guys would be
like why didn't the ad say coupon
salesman but every once in a while so
we'll be like I got the job and you're
like idiot yeah yeah you would you would
motivate these guys right you everything
you had a van and you drove them around
in a van yeah I bought a minivan the I
drove my crew around in my minivan and I
every morning posse my posse
yeah we drive we had a chance that we
did every morning I did we'd have a
morning meeting at 7:15 every day and
I'd come in with my coffee and I'd say
tell me how you feeling and it was
written on the wall and and most of
people who were there were new because
almost nobody lasted more than my
constant churn a lots of terrible yeah
and people would say you read along with
on the wall and you say fantastic
terrific great oh yes strong juice baby
sucker I feel wonderful right on right
on right on
juice juice juice juice juice I feel
great I feel great
hooah let's kick some ass kick some ass
who's number one we are who's number two
who cares
[Applause]
and then you'd say now let's go sell
Koopa yeah out of a van yeah we get in a
van and sell Koopa that part was written
in small tight yeah really small
congratulations you have a new baby boy
I do
that's fantastic how are you hello
Justin um we're Justin well he's home
he's four months old he was born
premature so he went through some some
emotional times when yeah but he's
healthy and he's happy and he does his
exercises every day and he's just what
exercises do you do well you know just
like a big bench I put him on the bench
putting up like know he is doing well
yeah really thrive a he's super strong
wow we're a four month old yeah you know
you move as you move him and bicycle and
up and down and sigh but I think
actually have a little video he made a
video and and and and your loss it
sounds like in this video you're
motivating him yeah yeah he listened to
hip hop when I exercise four month old
and so he because of genetics I think he
likes to listen hip hop - let's take a
look at this cliff how y'all doing all
yeah alright alright yo yo yo throw your
feet in the air go your feet in the air
yeah can I get everybody clap yo feet
yeah Oh Jack's gonna do his exercise
exercise Jack gonna do his exercise go
up and down side to side down up side to
side apart together apart together now
bicycle ride that bicycle
now criss-cross applesauce and crisp
through your feet in the air
[Music]
[Applause]